hi herzlich willkommen zum heutigen
video leute meinte nicht auch dass die
tonqualität ein bisschen besser sein
könnte so in etwa zum beispiel ja ich
habe mich dieses wunderbare mikrofons
abgefälscht von meinem video gesehen von
pure zugeschickt bekommen ich krieg
dafür kein geld versuchen sondern wollte
einfach mal durch die erwähnung quasi
danke sagen dass ich das bekommen habe
ihr merkt gleich ich schwitze total und
ich bin auch schon den ganzen tag
irgendwie so am rumpf stagnieren kommen
nicht wirklich voran
aber ich dachte mir heute musste mal
wieder video machen ich habe überlegt
und dann bin ich einfach mal auf twitter
gegangen nach meiner twitter timeline
habe ich einen post gesehen von ich
hoffe ich spricht ja auch janes fragment
das ist ein photoshop künstler bzw er
treue könnte man sagen der fotos
zugeschickt bekommt mit der bitte von
leuten dass sie zum beispiel besser
darauf aussehen sollen oder was weiß ich
vielleicht auch schlanker gemacht werden
oder reich oder was auch immer
irgendwelche leute die verbesserungen an
sich wollen und er macht das immer nicht
so ganz wie die leute sich vorgestellt
haben und darf ich euch heute mal zehn
bilder vorstellen einfach weil so alt
kleiner lückenfüller bis dann wiederum
richtiges video kommt so leute dann
legen wir los mit dem allerersten bild
und ich sagen ich sterbe gerade weil ich
sehr schätze aber es ist schon direkt
ziemlich lustig er stark ein mädchenheim
jamie kennedy mcmahon ridge sie erst mal
finde ich die sehen doch schon relativ
rasch auf die beiden so schicker
gigantische patent aber jay freeman die
legende
übrigens was von e-mails alten
abschreibung natürlich kann alles machen
und was macht er ihm einen patch oder
photoshop ihm ein patch aus seinen auf
dein hemd wo richard draufsteht weil
abgetupft von richard ist rich haben wir
gedacht oder leute also hast du das
gemacht ist ein solider einstieg würde
ich sagen ich hab es die meisten bilder
davon schon gesehen dass es für die mega
überraschung für mich gleich unterrichts
zu überlassen ich finde es sehr amüsant
bis nächstes foto da sind drei mädels
die in der mitte des deutlich kleiner
wie man sehen kann
das schreibt eine von den äußeren can
you make my friend in der mitte des fan
hat es also kannst du quasi die größte
fahne mit
so anpassen dass die so groß ist wie wir
denn trieb man wieder schuhe sein
lieblings antwort was macht er
erwartet wird die beiden äußeren frauen
so dass jetzt knien auf dem boden und
genau so groß sind wie die mittlere frau
glaube das war nicht so ganz in sinne
ich glaube das war nicht so ganz im
sinne der personen die angefragt hat
aber erst muss man halt mit rechnen wenn
man ihn fragt wenn ihr übrigens was auch
mal machen wollte dass ich quasi die
bilder photoshop dein leben schon mal
ein bisschen zeit und bearbeiteten paar
bilder die mir auf twitter zu schreiten
die kommentar beziehungsweise lasten
like daneben jetzt also als exempel für
euch dass ihr wisst wie das ganze
abläuft und dann machen wir vielleicht
auch mal so eine photoshop troll sache
natürlich kann ich das nicht so gut wie
nichts foto hey james kenny mckinley
gleich ein feigling den gruß da ist ein
mann der mit einer ganz zusammen ein
bild hast und nächste foto ich lasse
sogar lustiger weise vielleicht kennen
wir von euch goldene aktie sieht man die
ganz vorne links im vordergrund und er
sei jemand der halt ähnlich farbige
klamotten an hat wie er ist komplett in
den boden gehämmert und dem street
manager dazu nur eins zu null für die
ganz wahrscheinlich auch wieder ein
klassik also muss man sagen ist ein
lustiger typ auf jeden fall auch sehr
respektabel was du da keine arbeit rein
steckt die kleinen lustigen druck raus
brown
über die arbeit auch verkauft irgendwie
ob er da irgendwie geld mit mache aber
so oder so verluste ich übrigens andere
coole leute wie zum beispiel steven
mcmenamy auf instagram fcs mcmenamy der
macht so kommt die fotos in dem zum
beispiel keine ahnung helfen von einem
megafon und obendrauf für 31 buchbinder
sieht dass wir auch wieder einfache kann
sich gut vorstellen aber nur der
künstler so und nächste anfrage
vater und sohn sind auf dem bild und der
vater schreibt gute priester nennt
werner herzog cool
er möchte gerne coolere der möchtegern
kunde versuchte sich und seinen sohn
was glaubt ihr glaubt ihr das ist ein
problem für james morgan freeman
das verwirrt mich erst da kein event ist
denn da haben sie recht ein problem ich
glaube nicht was macht er das foto an
auf den allerersten blick fällt gar
nicht auf aber er hat einfach den bars
vom vater genommen und hat den hals
haare vom sohn verwendet und die haare
von sohn auf den kopf vom vater
verwendet hat den vater sondern auch
richtig detailverliebten doppelkinn
eingeführt der vater die direkt dem
jünger-haus rating nächstes bild auch
safari hier eine ladies ride the trash
kämpfern picture weil die anscheinend
das foto cool finden und das gerne für
irgendwie sowas verwenden möchte in der
rechten seite wie man halt diese
mülltonne im bild wir können ja immer so
ein bisschen überlegen was er jetzt
machen würde
ich hätte zum beispiel als erste das
wahrscheinlich dass er sie jetzt weg
photoshop so als gewissen träsch kann
aber nein er hat es ganz anders gemacht
und zwar hat er einfach tatsächlich die
trash can also quasi den mülleimer weg
gemacht aber den müll da gelassen weil
es eigentlich das einzige wonach die
gefragt hat um ja das produkt die da
drüben liegt überall auf dem boden ok
länger ein bisschen vor jamie kannst du
das bis zu bearbeiten dass der flamingo
und der mülleimer nicht mehr hinter mir
sind vielen dank
klar hätte ihn was macht uns wird man
natürlich er schiebt die sache vor sie
weil sie sollen ja nicht mehr hinter ihr
seien sehr gut der junge mann hier
bittet gainey darum dass er mehr als
aussehen soll er so viel besser aussehen
soll ganz glatt gelaufen kurz euch
selbst an
es sieht auf jeden fall nicht so dass
auch mit dem schaum auf dem kopf und
dann der ente und dem babbel bei etwas
für hinten eingefügt wurde auf jeden
fall mal wieder eine sehr ehrenmann
aktion 1 media machen fifi im aus und
schreibt kelly please make it looks
raunt er antwortet okay ich mache
natürlich aber er hat wieder übertrieben
der kopf ist jetzt ein viereck es gibt
so manche leute ich glaube auch von
arrow zum beispiel der charakter ich
weiß nicht wie der schauspieler ist
dabei auch von connor kann irgendwas gar
nicht gern auch ungefähr so von natur
aus dem kopf so ein kind richtig krank
nächste kreuzfahrt ein pärchen hat
wahrscheinlich für sie das beste foto
aller zeiten geschossen und was stört
projekt dass diese eine frau sie an
glotzt wie lösen
problem wir fragen jamie ob er seine
photoshop street films spielen lassen
kann
sie glaube zwar noch genauso aber diesen
einfach nicht mehr dazu gibt es
natürlich auch das milieu links fragt ob
das bild so bearbeitet werden kann das
auch wie im rahmen ist ja gerät das
resultat wie ist jetzt im rahmen aber
halten nur noch sie in der halbe kopf
von einer ihrer freunde oder kollegen
werferin
das war schon drei plätze foto leute das
war heute mein maximum kötter und
einbeziehung einfacheres video für mich
ich hoffe mein vater ich trotzdem
irgendwie unterhalten checkt unbedingt
in künstler aus so ein bisschen schlecht
wenn ich so ein video machen wo ich
quasi die sachen von anderen vorstelle
aber auf der anderen seite ist natürlich
auch eine gute möglichkeit den leuten
eine plattform zu geben wenn man das
heißt alles richtig und transparent
macht dass man sagt von daher ist dafür
die es an schau dir das was man heute
wir sehen uns für mich mal wieder unter